enemy's surging in multiple sectors LT
they're taking ground let's keep this on
a tight loop and get back out there race
captain on the bridge
get us underway so right away sir
captain has the Conn Raven 1 docking
you're touching down ammo good stations
I have one minute Roger that
we've got four new hotspots on radar sir
check applauded course on you order sir
what's our target race
stand by for objective we've got a set
depth destroyer in lunar orbit will
coordinate a takedown with tigress let's
mount up lieutenant
and his what the Jackals up on Bay three
captain thanks chief
captain Keith is already in Bexar you
said Ethan good to go sir
so we should be study good on cap thanks
80 so great on the catapult you spun out
favorite crime novel get hit
at five
check 1 1
Latika lumia
launcher go Roger will it launch in 3 2
1
they're launching sculptors
I got one on me countermand
I got it
I'm going not going these
easy
can brush the Raider throttle up
I'm a Julia
box out
actual Raiders inbound aboard and
disable enemy warships standby
iZON Tigers for visual
scarf jack is down
one one is away ahead sir
right let's get there we got hustles
coming
Center transport inbound
did
37
Oh
keep pushing
oh great top of the bridge
sodas clear here's our info that blast
shields are up copy tigress we are
exterior the bridge preparing the bridge
for soon let's go
staff sergeant cover the exit Ethan
restore life support
aye sir so let's cope the windows I get
the CEOs card
gravity tygris actual weapons are down
moving to exfil
second level one minute let's go
Jilla
depressurizing grab hold
tygris we need first
all right
coppy
turn a bird
time for scars are clear I'm a clear
engaging
our blood has been spilled
looks like everyday
dang
Marines we have a possible fixin on the
side of the capital city Intel gathered
by SAS indicates that Assad may have a
Russian warhead speed is critical we
have visual on target eta 66
oh Claire
get up
beautiful
we are leaving
let's do this